Let's go next to our caller from the eight
one four area code. Who's calling today from
eight one four.
Hey, this is Evan. Hey David. Not much. Um,
first of all, you're my favorite political
commentator on the internet or like, and,
and the, uh, really liked Watson, went on
the Rajoy. Yeah. Uh, so, so my question was,
um, it seems like the moderators really went
after Bernie last night. They made the cost
of attending $1,750. So obviously is the majority
of his base, had no way of going, um, particularly
in South, uh, South Carolina. Right. So, um,
I, I'm wondering what you think about this.
Does do you think this, um, concerted effort
from the DNC to suppress Bernie and go after
him actually helps him? As in if you think
they were burning neutral, do you think he'd
be in a worse position in the polls because
after the debate CDs, his own survey of audiences
asking them who did the best on the debate?
31 that, which, you know, I P it seems like
people are missing.
Is that, was that a, was that a website survey
or where was that survey?
Um, I'm not sure. I just saw it on YouTube
right after the, um, I
just saw the thumbnail. I didn't click on
the video. I don't want to get to CVS.
Yeah, I mean, listen, it's conceivable that
there's something to what you're saying that
by sort of going after Bernie, they are helping
him because people see that he's being attacked.
I guess we'll know after super Tuesday, right?
Super Tuesday is going to be a pretty decisive
day. There will be one of three outcomes at
super Tuesday. Either Bernie will do so well
that he will have a very clear path to 50%
plus one delegates. Either the results will
be so split that the most likely outcome will
be nobody gets to 50% plus one, but Bernie
has a plurality or Bernie will do so poorly
on super Tuesday that he won't even be on
a path to a plurality of the delegates. I
don't think that last one is likely. I think
one of the first two situations is likely
and we'll just have to wait and see because
we, we just have not had enough votes, votes
cast yet to know what the effect on Bernie
support has been so far from the, the corporate
media and DNC opposition to Bernie. But we're
only like five days from figuring that out.
Yeah. So I'm crossing my fingers.
All right. Thank you so much. I appreciate
the phone call. Great to hear from you and
uh, appreciate the kind words as well.